web 3 is the newest buzzword taking over
the tech adventure capital world and if
you found yourself wondering what it
means you're not alone web 3 is seen as
the third generation of the internet a
decentralized online ecosystem based on
the blockchain
web 3 represents kind of a new
philosophy about how to realize these
technologies in a more distributed and
democratic way venture capitalists have
invested billions into this vision but
some tech experts are unconvinced that
web 3 could scale globally
skeptics like tesla ceo elon musk have
called it a marketing buzzword
a lot of the skepticism about web 3.0
comes from the fact that its early
expressions are fairly primitive as
experts debate whether or not this new
version of the web can become a reality
here are some of the underlying
principles behind the vision for web 3.0
to better understand web 3.0
and what sets it apart from the web we
use today you have to go back to the
early days of the internet what experts
now refer to as web 1.0
most of the participants were content
consumers who were limited to navigating
through individual static web pages web
1.0 for those who remember was just you
know raw html
and lots of very simple web pages and it
wasn't really controlled by anybody this
was a more decentralized version of the
web meaning anyone who knew how to code
could build on it from their own
computers but at this time only a small
number of users had the technical skills
to create and publish content
then came web 2.0 which is the stage of
the internet we're living through now
web technologies like javascript and
html5 made the internet more interactive
allowing startups to build platforms
like facebook google amazon and many
others
for the first time anyone could publish
content online even if they couldn't
code web 2.0 is this modern centralized
version of the web you know we're all
sharing things on
social media which are owned by you know
only two or three companies and we're
all using google search
these companies own and manage the data
collected from their users and they
frequently track and save this data and
use it for targeted ads
what's at the core of their business
model is data olga mac is a blockchain
lecturer at uc berkeley and is
optimistic about web3's potential to
reshape the internet the data economy
where the user generated content whether
it's a conversation or a video that is
exchanged for services and so there is a
perception that
this monopoly of data
could be abused here's where the vision
for web 3.0 comes in the term web 3 was
first coined by one of the creators of
the ethereum blockchain gavin wood in a
2014 blog post wood envisioned web3 as
an open and decentralized version of the
internet theoretically users would be
able to exchange money and information
on the web without the need for a
middleman like a bank or a tech company
in this vision for web3 world people
would have more control over their data
and be able to sell it if they choose
and it would all be operated on a
decentralized distributed ledger
technology the most common version of
this is known as the blockchain while
still considered relatively new and
unproven it could offer more
transparency and autonomy for users
the computers that are actually
doing that computing for you or storing
that data anyone could own those
computers anyone can become a part of
that blockchain and so it's not facebook
and google's computers doing that with a
single personalized account users would
theoretically be able to move seamlessly
from social media to email to shopping
creating a public record on the
blockchain of all that activity
but how exactly would web3 remain
operational if it's not controlled by a
central corporation or entity
theoretically people would be given
virtual tokens or cryptocurrencies to
incentivize them to participate in the
operation of web3 a central element of
this system is so-called defy or
decentralized finance
and the idea is that if you can issue a
token for everything in the universe if
you can financialize every possible
interaction of computers and software
and humans
then you can create this vast ecosystem
of cryptocurrencies which can be traded
which can be valued relative to one
another
still it's unclear how this
decentralized token system would be
regulated how it could operate on a
large scale or even how well it would
distribute control of the internet
critics of the idea like twitter
co-founder jack dorsey called web3 a
centralized entity with a different
label
developers who really dug into this
think that the underlying blockchain
structures of web 3.0 are
very insecure
not decentralized as promised they're
actually as centralized as the previous
technologies some see web 3.0 as a
critical building block in creating the
metaverse an immersive online world
where people can use avatars to
socialize shop work and play
but others say web3 and the metaverse
are two very different concepts because
the metaverse is being hyped a lot right
now and web3 is there are some companies
at the intersection of the two like
let's create a metaverse that
you know somehow is connected to the
blockchain right now web3 is still very
much an abstract concept with little
real-world foundation skeptics like
engineer and blogger steven deal argue
that web 3.0 doesn't have the computing
power bandwidth or storage to work on
any practical level
for skeptics of web 3 their argument is
that um you know tokens and
cryptocurrencies in general are just a
giant bubble and as soon as it pops uh
in their view all of this nonsense about
how that's going to build the next
internet will go away
while it remains to be seen whether or
not web3 will become a reality the
philosophy behind it is driving billions
in investments in the venture capital
world funding a vast ecosystem of
decentralized internet services
so there's so much
real world money going into building
web3 startups that
even if as a concept it proves
unworkable
we're going to be hearing about it for a
long time yet to come
you